une production du studio
SF bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos invités
d' animé par moi-même Dom plant et pH
qutin et aujourd'hui on parle
d'environnement ça faisait longtemps que
je vouis faire un épisode sur
l'environnement où est-ce qu'on en est
est-ce que ça va aussi mal qu'on dit
c'est quoi la science derrière ça c'est
quoi les projection c'est sur le futur
est-ce qu'on fon dans un mur où est-ce
que on va s'en sortir toutes des
question que j'ai posé à Isabelle chon
et Dominique Paquin qui travaill les
deux chez Uranus Isabelle Charon qui est
chef de trans transfer de la
connaissance et formation et Dominique
Parin qui est spécialiste en simulation
et analyse climatique ça ce que c'est
entre autres c'est que uranos fait des
simulations finalement sur le futur donc
à l'aide de technologie d'ordinateur et
de beaucoup beaucoup de données sont
capables de dire bon ben si on continue
sur cette trajectoire voici à quoi
ressemblerait le monde en 2000 sang euh
en terme de réchauffement climatique et
toutes les conséquences qui auraiit euh
qui ça aurait sur notre monde et il y a
tout un aspect churanos aussi sur
l'adaptation l'adaptation dans dans le
fond c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour se
parer au changement climatique qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire euh ça peut toucher euh
vraiment plein d'aspect inondation
catastrophe naturelle feu de forêt
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour se préparer à
tous ces changements qui s'en viennent
pour s'adapter finalement pour survivre
à ce cette transformation du monde qui
qui est inévitable en fait
euh donc un sujet vraiment est fascinant
vraiment puis ce qui était beau dans
cette discussion là aussi c'est qu'il y
a une certaine lueur d'espoir des fois
qu'on parle d'environnement
euh ben soit en fait on y croit pas du
tout ou soit ben la fin du monde
approche puis on va tous mourir et d'
euh CIT rafraîchissant quand même de de
de voir que oui a des grands défis qui
nous attendent oui il faut absolument
faire quelque chose mais qu' il y en a
des actions concrètes qui sont prises
puis on va
probablement survivre à tout ça donc yes
ça part bien donc ben je vous laisse
avec l'épisode là on va rentrer vraiment
plus en détail dans toute dans tous ces
sujets là donc bonne écoute le podcast
d'aujourd'hui est présenté par
manscape et le temps des fêtes approche
et si vous avez toujours pensé peut-être
acheter un package manscape vous avez
besoin de renouveler vos produits
manscape c'est le moment de vous faire
un cadeau à vous ou à l'être aimé ou à
votre père à votre cousin à votre chien
n'importe qui qui a besoin peêre pas
votre chien qui a besoin de produits
pour hom des produits faits
pour la gestion de la pilosité sur tout
le corps et également des produits pour
sentir
bon c'est vraiment les meilleurs
produits ça fait assez longtemps qu'
qu'on vous en parle je pense que là
c'est vraiment le moment de faire le
Move surtout qu' a un nouveau package
qui est sorti on vous a parlé de l' 2. 0
3.0 ben là sont rendus imaginez-vous
donc au 5.0 et il y a tout un package
c'est le performance package 5.0 ultra
là-dedans vous avez le nouveau rosoir
électrique avec lequel maintenant il y a
deux lames une lame standard et une lame
encore plus fine et précise pour aller
vraiment dans tous les recoins possibles
et imaginables que vous voulez raser
avec ça on a le wiedwer 2.0 qui est pour
la gestion des poils de nez et des poils
d'oreille alors des beau des poils de
nez qui dépassent c'est jamais le fun
avec avec ça c'est réglé pour toujours
et avec ça dans le package vient tous
les
produits
déodorant tous les produits finalement
pour sentir bon et on a les boxeurs 2.0
que moi les boxeurs mascape c'est mes
boxeurs préférés je trouve c'est les
plus confortable maintenant il encore
amélioré donc c'est tous les produits
que vous connaissez mais maintenant
encore à un autre niveau supérieur moi
je le dis vraiment sans sans g c'est
meilleurs produit pour meilleur r
électrique que j'ai utilisé là
maintenant c'est encore sont encore
meilleurs donc
c'est c'est M pas imaginable comment ça
va bien comment que c'est la qualité
donc temp des fêtes on en profite en
plus il y a un Rabet avec le code promo
sans filtre pour 20 % de Rabet sur votre
commande mcape alors nésitez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas
c'est parti un TR Go c'est parti bonjour
de façon aussi naturelle que ça ouais
merci beaucoup d'être là fait plaisir
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment fun Dom
comme comme Dom vous vous disait avant
qu'on commence à enregistrer quand qu'on
a voulu parler d'environnement ben le
nom
anos est revenu beaucoup est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer globalement à nous
et surtout aux auditeurs uranos c'est
quoi
mais an sétait créé il y a plus d'une
vingtaine d'années maintenant euh et en
fait c'était pour répondre à une
question que le gouvernement du Québec
se posait parce qu'il y avait eu deux
événements extrêmes qui s'étaient
produit le déluge du sagné et la crise
du Vergl et donc le constat qu'ils ont
fait c'est ok les changements
climatiques sont présents on sait pas si
on peut attribuer ces événements là au
changements climatiques mais on voudrait
se préparer parce que quand on est pas
prêt ça coûte cher ça fait ce que ça
fait au sagné là exactement c'est ça ça
coûte cher à tous les niveaux OK
oui mais si on est prêt ça va être un il
va on ve éviter que ça recoûte cher ben
on diminue les les risques donc à ce
moment-là le gouvernement a décidé de
regrouper de créer un consortium ce qui
était très innovateur à l'époque même
encore maintenant pour regrouper les
gens vraiment en science du climat mais
vraiment aussi ajouter une composante
très importante qui est l'adaptation au
changement climatique et donc en
regroupant tout ce monde là il on créé
uranos donc c'est un consortium dans
lequel il y a le gouvernement du Québec
mais également quatre universités euh et
d'autres partenaires qui VO qui étaient
là au départ comme Environnement Canada
et Hydro Québec ou qui se sont joints au
fil des temps comme par exemple le crime
euh les villes Québec de Montréal euh
qu'est-ce que d'autre aussi j'en échappe
sûrement routinto ALC épque c'est ça
c'est pas mal ça ouais donc le but
d'Ouranos c'est de créer de
l'information scientifique de qualité
mais vraiment pour permettre à la
société québécoise de s'adapter au
changement climatique hm hm quand on
parle d'adaptation au changement
climatique euh moi ça me crée l'anxiété
parce que c'est d'un peu d'admettre que
les changements climatiques sont bien
engagés et que là la solution c'est
d'essayer de voir qu'est-ce qu'on fait
quand qu' vair des catastrophes
climatiques en fait comment est-ce que
on
réconcilie l'idée de vouloir ralentir
les changements climatiques mais en même
temps de se préparer à les vivre mais
c'est une question importante les les
gens comme tu tu dis ont tendance à à
associer adaptation avec un lâcher prise
un déftis on il est trop tard on peut
plus rien faireimession d'amener des
sacs de sable devant nos maisons
seulement faire ça c'est pas ça qu'on
dit du tout on est on est dans une
position aujourd'hui où on parle de
lutte au changement climatique il faut
faire absolument les deux il est pas
trop tard on doit continuer à réduire
nos émissions de gaz à effet ser pour
justement diminuer au maximum les
changements climatiques qui s'en
viennent mais en même temps les choix
qu'on fait aujourd'hui en terme de
réduction ils sont pas immédiats dans
l'atmosphère on va pas sentir les effets
de nos réductions tout de suite il va
quand même y avoir des changements
climatiques qui vont continuer à se
produire puis on on a déjà des
changements climatiques sur le
territoire donc il faut quand même se
préparer premièrement réagir à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui et continuer de
trouver des solutions d'adaptation qui
vont nous aider comme vous le dites à
réduire les coûts à diminuer les risques
à mieux préparer les populations nos
infrastructures à ce qui s en vient de
façon inévitable même si on coupait la
champlure Dominique peut vous en vous
entretenir davantage là-dessus si on
coupait la champlure à zéro aujourd'hui
on arrêtait d' mettre complètement il y
a il y a un effet qui va quand même
perdurer la rue continue la roue
continue de tourner effectivement donc
on n pas le choix on veut vraiment faire
ce qu'on appelle la lutte donc sur les
deux fronts sans baisser les bras puis
dire ben il est trop tard il faut juste
s'adapter c'est pas ça du tout si si
j'ai bien compris euh chacune travailler
dans une de ces deux branches là si je
comprends bien c'est ça ben en fait moi
je je travaille plus en vulgarisation
scientifique je suis moins dans la
science du climat je suis quelqu'un qui
va justement euh prendre ce que l'équipe
de Scien du climat produit puis aller
apporter ce message envers les gens qui
doivent prendre des décisions qui
doivent s'adapter sur le territoire donc
je suis plus du côté l'explication des
impacts qu'est-ce qui s'en vient à quoi
faut se préparer et justement la
recherche de de solutions OK ou alors
alors que de mon côté je suis vraiment
en science du climat à la base si vous
me demandez ce que je fais je travaille
en modélisation climatique régionale qui
est très spécifique donc on a un modèle
de climat avec lequel on fait des
simulations donc on produit des données
qui sont utilisées par les gens vraiment
pour adapter ces donnéeslà de manière à
ce qu'elle soit utilisable par les gens
qui ont besoin de prendre des décisions
il y a plusieurs centres de modélisation
dans le monde qui ont des modèles
différents donc on rassemble les données
produites un peu partout de manière à
produire l'information comme jeis qui
est vraiment adapté pour les les les les
besoins
qu'on va appeler les les décideurs mais
qui est un terme très générique pour
près n'importe qui qui a besoin d'avoir
des données donc c'est ça donc le but de
faire des prédictions de ce qui s'en
vient selon tel scénario là tu sais donc
si on réduit pas par exemple nos GS il
pourra arriver ça selon euh toutes les
données qu'on a rentré dans l'ordinateur
puis qui nous a dit ça va donner ça oui
le terme technique qu'on lo c'est des
projections les prédictions c'est un peu
autre chose mais c'est quand on utilise
des scénarios d'émissions pour les
émission g AFF du futur l'utilisation
des sols du futur et tout ça on appelle
ça des projections effectivement c'est
ça c'est sur ce genre de de projection
là qu'on qu'on se base pour dire ok ben
là on veut d'ici tu on a parlait je vous
disais qu'on avait reçu Stepen gilbau
sur le Podcast il disait bon on veut
selon l'accord de Paris si je me trompe
pas maximum 2 degrés d'ici 2100 c'est à
partir de j'imagine de de projections
comme ça qu'on peut dire ben si on fait
quelque chose ça c'est possible puis les
conséquences vont être à peu près ça oui
exactement ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que les scénarios d'émission donc
vement la base soit les émissions de gaz
effet s changement d'utilisation des
sols ça c'est pas fait par nous c'est en
fait c'est s le chapeau de de l'ONU ou
de l'OMM l'organisation mondiale la
météo du GC et tout ça donc il y a des
scénarios qui sont utilisés par tous les
centres de modélisation dans le monde
donc on rentre ces données là dans nos
modèles qui vont réagir à ça pour
produire effectivement les projections
les simulations du futur et selon ce
qu'on a euh mis en entrée dans les
modèles on va se retrouver avec des
réchauffements variables à une certaine
date h ça l'équipe de Dominique l'équipe
de de science du climat chez nous ce
qu'ils font c'est justement on parle de
2 degrés mais 2 degrés c'est une moyenne
à l'échelle de la planète ouais 2 degrés
ça veut rien dire à Montréal à Québec ou
nunavic si les degrés sont pas répartis
euh c'est pas un réchauffement égal
partout donc on essaie de comprendre ce
qui va se passer de façon régionale chez
nous pour être mieux adapté parce que le
2 degrés ou le 1.5°gr c'est vraiment une
moyenne mondiale puis ça ça de prendre
une décision là-dessus fait pas
nécessairement beaucoup de sens selon où
on est ouais puis avant de parler de de
ce qui s'en vient parce que tu sais les
réchauements climatiques on on parle
souvent du futur mais on est déjà dedans
dans le sens que tu sais euh c'est déjà
commencé puis on voit les effets puis tu
sais on parlait de la crise du Vergl
plutôt euh par exemple ça est-ce que
est-ce que on peut dire de tout doute
que c'est des phénomènes qui qui sont
causés par les changements climatiques
ou pas néement non c'est pas comme ça
que ça fonctionne ça c'est la science
qu'on appelle de l'attribution là et bon
ok juste faire une mise en garde plus
loin les changements climatiques là
c'est très large ok donc moi en fait tu
me demandz vraiment ce que je fais je
travaille en modélisation régionale
spécialiste à convection ok fait juste
pour dire que vous avez posé plein de
questions on va répondre au mieux de nos
connaissance mais donc on n pas des
spécialistes de l'attribution mais je
peux vous dire que ok on peut jamais
attribuer un mais
c'est j'espère sinon pour qu'on change
de place c'est ça c'est ça mais comment
ça fonctionne c'est qu'on peut faire une
série de simulations dans lequelle on
change pas le climat une série de
simulations dans lequelle on change le
climat et on va comparer les deux et
donc on va pouvoir attribuer des
probabilités ok ouis euh mais on peut
pas dire cet événement là est causé par
les changements climatiques c'est ça
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche mais
par exemple il y a eu des études qui ont
été fait pour les feux de forêt au
printemps et on peut dire qu's sont deux
fois plus prob probable à cause des
changements climatiques mais il ça
aurait pu se produire sans changement
climatique quand on remonte dans le
passé souvent on peut trouver des
événements semblables même si on a des
données météo sur assez peu de temps 100
ans 150 ans quelque chose comme ça euh
c'est ça mais donc on peut dire la
probabilité que ces événementsl étit
soit plus intense ou plus fréquent à
cause des changements climatique quand
qu'on compare qu qu'on dit mettons deux
fois plus fréquent c'est par rapport à
avant l'air industriel c'est par rapport
à à quoi en fait mais la la la vraie
formulation si on suit ce que le J le
groupe Groupe intergouvernemental
d'experts sur les climat qui est le truc
de l'ONU qui produit des rapports à
toutes les qui mettent qui nous
inquièteent tous plus à chaque année ex
cause
de ex ceux dont le rapport et le rapport
qui nous tente le moins de
lire un article commence
avec une bonne nouvelle c'est rarement
non on pour revenir mais a quand même
des Bones nouvelles euh puis là j'ai
perdu de qu'est-ce que je voulais dire
déjà mais je posé la question est-ce
queire oui c'est ça oui euh donc la
vraie période de référence c'est
toujours par rapport euh à Laons 1850 à
1900 ok qui moment où la révolution
industrielle est déjà enclenchée mais où
il y a pas encore d'effet sur le climat
ok fait quand on veut se comparer c'est
dans ces eau-là souvent c'est fait d'une
manière un peu moins orthodoxe soit
parce qu'on a pas de données ou parce
qu'on va se comparer par exemple à ce
que les les les les gens se rappellent
si je parle
je vous me dis le climat qu'il y avait
en 1850 bon hein c'est ça alors que si
je vous dis dans les années 70 dans les
années 60 les bandage était plus haut
don ça va dire quelque chose aux gens
mais la vraie référence c'est toujours
par rapport à la euh avant la révolution
industrielle mais avant avant que çait
un effet sur le climat donc oui ça on va
dire c'est deux fois plus probable c'est
par rapport à un climat où il y a pas eu
de de changement climatique en tropique
ok mais mais même sur une période de 30
50 ans on on on le voit on le remarque
c'est on pas besoin de regarder 150 ans
en arrière 150 ans en arrière pour voir
les changements oui mais pour l'attribué
de manière statistique c'est autre chose
et souvent si on parle d'événements qui
sont très rares c'est encore plus ça
demande encore plus de données plus long
terme et on a peu
d'observation météorologique qui à long
terme font du climat là donc c'est pour
ça qu'on utilise des modèles aussi parce
qu'avec les modèles on peut retourner
dans le passé on peut faire des
simulations sans changement climatique
et là on peut en faire autant qu'on veut
donc on a plein de données donc on peut
faire l'attribution statistique à l' des
modèles OK puis ce ce cette comparaison
entre les pourcentages là qu'on qu'on
vient de parler là tu le deux fois plus
de chance d'avoir des feux de forêt
souvent les gens utilisent des exemples
anecdotiques qui ont lieu dans les
années 40 ben les gens je dis les gens
comme s'il y avait une grande population
de climatosceptique mais souvent les
gens qui qui veulent un peu repousser le
les changements climatiques ou le le
concept de changement climatique vont
aller chercher des anecdotes comme ça
que s'est déjà produit moi je me
rappelle l'année passée en novembre l'
année euh ouais en novembre il y avait
eu une comme 3 jours vraiment vraiment
chaud là où est-ce qu'on était comme ça
pas de bon sang qu' en novembre il f me
rappelle j'étais en T-shirt sur le
plateau Montroyal je comprenais comme
pas puis là il y a comme une statistique
sortie ah mais c'est même pas le plus
chaud qu' a fait en novembre en 1900 je
sais pas quoi il a fait plus chaud que
ça puis je me rappelle d'avoir entendu
le discours de fa vous voyez c'est ça
qui ça qui arrive fait le fait qu'on est
capable de calculer le taux de
pourcentage de chance que ça se produit
j'imagine que c'est quand même un bon
argument pour pour les les changements
climatiques en fait pour prouver le pas
prouver le existance comme si on avait
besoin de le prouver mais pour démontrer
l'importance des changements climati oui
mais c'est un peu ce que je disis c'est
des événements froid ou catastrophique
il y en a eu dans le passé la différence
c'est la fréquence ou l'intensité ou le
territoire que ça va couvrir il y a des
choses qui se produisait plus au sud et
maintenant qui vont se produire plus au
nord tu sais ce genre de truc là c'est
sû quand on peut le qu
de manière numérique et de façon
scientifique à l'aide de modèle ben
évidemment
ça c'est ça ça aide pas
ça aux explications à la clarification
de l'idé c'est sûr que les gens ont
tendance à oublier que le climat change
de façon naturelle aussi d'une année à
l'autre si je vous demande de réfléchir
à votre date de fête dans les 5
dernières années c'est probableement pas
la même journée donc cette variabilité
là naturelle elle va perdurer dans le
temps il va continue à avoir des hauts
il va continuer à avoir des bas même si
la tendance de fond est au réchauffement
puis quand on parle de changement
climatique c'est cette tendance sur un
très long terme qu'on essaie de de
regarder on regarde pas comme tu dis un
événement qui se produit à un moment
donné parce que ça varie d'une année à
l'autre puis ça ça va continuer à être
le cas puis justement par rapport à à
notre point de référence en date
d'aujourd'hui on en est où dans le sens
un point un point 1 point je pense
1. d'augmentation par rapport à la 1850
1900 gr là donc on a déjà gagné 1,1 degr
ouais ouais obseris ça
dans les conséquences de ça parce que tu
sais 1
degré pour pour bien du monde c'est
c'est l'IV est peut-être un peu plus
court puis d'A puis ouais mais si je te
dis qu'une glaciation c'est entre 4 5
degr de changement est-ce que tu peux
comprendre que le 1 degré est
importantation
étantou oui exactement oui c'est ça en
moyen parce que c'est ça c'est ce
qu'Isabelle disait tout à l'heure le 1
degr c'est une valeur moyenne sur le
globe ouais il faut penser qu'au Canada
parce qu'on est tout latitude nordique
c'est à peu près le double puis si on
vaend en Arctique c'est à peu près trois
fois plus OK et ça c'est une valeur
moyenne OK et faut comprendre que en
fait les températures les plus froides
se réchauffent plus la nuit ça se
réchauffe plus ce qui fait qu'il a
certains endroitsis dans certains
extrêmes le réchauffement c'est pas un
c'est beaucoup plus que ça et c'est la
même chose quand on évid éventuellement
on va parler du futur là quand on parle
de 3 4 degrés de plus c'est encore en
moyenne donc 3 degrés de plus au niveau
global euh global c'est mondial là on se
retrouve avec Ben 6 degrés chez nous
9°grés en article c'est énorme sais puis
puis mais ENF que finalement ça se
manifeste comment ce degré.12 là déjà
aujourd'hui que ça soit tu sais la
question est large dans le sens que tu
sais je je sais que c'est infini là les
effets des changements climatiques là tu
sais puis et les feux de forêt les
inondations les C les ça euh c'est quoi
les mettons mettons qu'on qu'on en
sélectionne les plus majeurs déjà qu'on
observe puis qui qui sont g A qui impact
la vie des gens ben au Québec on on
découpe souvent le le Québec en
différents morceaux parce que les les
effets des changements climatiques les
impacts sont pas partout pareil si on
est dans le Nord c'est la fond du pergil
sol par exemple donc là on a des
infrastructures qui sont bâtis sur du
rock solide qui normalement devrait pas
dégeler quand ça commence à dégeler ben
c'est les infrastructures qui qui qui
sont mis à mal c'est des routes qui
gondolent c'est c'est un mode de vie des
gens qui sont là qui est complètement
détruit il y a plus de glace la chasse
on oublie ça sur la sur la glace les
routes de glace les routes de glace qui
sont utilisé qui ne qui sont de moins en
moins utilisés puis on est on est
aujourd'hui avec 1 degr comme Dominique
a dit si on se projette à 19°gr plus
plus est la dernière fois que j'ai
entendu PERG sol c'était en
[Rires]
son juste le mentionner en
géographie je en permanence je me
rappelle exactement c'est quoi ça veut
dire que ça l'occupe une partie de mon
cerveau depuis tout ce tempsl pu c'est
là puis ça dort c'est
dorm c'est fini
LEC euh pu dans le sud c'est l'inverse
là c'est des vagues de chaleur ou des
étés qui sont très très longs qui sont
plus longs on on commence l'été plusut
tôt génial on fini l'été plus tard comme
tu l'as dit tantôt génial mais entre ça
on ça veut dire que on a des vagues de
chaleur qui sont plus longues on a des
impacts sur les sur la cériculture
l'agriculture qui sont aussi importants
les gens sont pas nécessairement
préparés euh à tous ces bouversementsl
les les le système de santé va être
impacté en tourisme la neige en
hiver sur la côte on voit déjà beaucoup
d'épisodes de d'érosion côtière parce
qu'on a une perte de glace en hiver on a
des des surcottes des tempêtes des
surverses le niveau de la la mer qui
monte aussi donc on les voit déjà les
changements climatiques sur le
territoire québécois ça puis là si on se
projette on va se projeter mais
déjà c'est donc c'est ça on les on les
remarque comme comme vous dites ça ça
impacte tout les secteurs économique du
Québec nous on travaille sur une dizaine
douzaine de d'ux ça va être l'énergie
l'agriculture la forêt les
écosystèmes la santé le
tourisme la sécurité alimentaire
àouette NZ il y a un impact en quelque
part pu ça c'est au Québec après ça si
on essaie on on on réfléchit à ce qui se
passe au Québec est impacté forcément
par ce qui se passe ailleurs donc les
chaînes d'impact on importe des ch on
exporte des choses les changements
climatiques qui se passent dans les
autres pays ont un impact quand même
nous en terme de de d'économie de
manière générale oua juste pour
temporiser un petit peu parce que oui
c'est super important les changements
climatiques au Québec évidemment là mais
comparé à d'autres endroits dans le
monde je veux dire c'est ça c'est ça va
ok on on est on est un pays riche on est
déjà on est déjà en train d'étud
l'adaptation depuis une vingtaine
d'années on a des infrastructures
solides tu sais et par rapport au manque
d'eau qui est une qui va être vraiment
une préoccupation majeure dans plein
d'endroits dans le monde on n'est pas à
risque oui en été il va avoir des
changements on va avoir moins d'eau en
été bon des vagues de chaleur et tout ça
mais globalement sur l'année on sera pas
un pays où on va manquer d'eau il y a
des endroits dans le monde où ça va se
produire et à ce moment-là ça amène
d'autres bouleversements beaucoup
socioppolitiques socio-économiques qui
ont des conséquences évidemment de
population d à des sécheresses ou des
sécheresses qui amèent des enjeux bon
politiques et cetera donc au Québec
quand
même c'est ça on est bien là juste pour
diminuer
lesxi est-ce
que est-ce que ça
précisément c'est une des en fait moi
j'imagine le Québec de par l'accès à
l'eau de par le vaste territoire qu'on
manquera presque jamais tu sais je le
Québec c'est énorme est-ce que Québec
devient comme une possiblement une
destination future pour les futurs
réfugiés climatiques lorsqu'il y en aura
ok là tu sors vraiment de nos champs
d'expertise mais si tu vux avoir notre
avis personnel c'est clair que moi je
dirais que oui tu sais parce que il y a
des endroits dans le monde qui seront
plus habitables simplement là fait que
comme je dis au Québec oui on va avoir
des problèmes il faut vraiment se
préparer mais bon je pense qu'on peut
être une t d'accueil assez facilement
mais là encore une fois on comprend
compr disclaimer puis quand puis quand
quand on parle il y a pire ailleurs les
pires endroits c'est c'est les endroits
les plus chauds en fait so c'est c'est
quoi les pires endroits les
endroits moins favorisés en fait
j'imagine oui mais beaucoup d'endroits
où en fait si on si on pouvit avoir une
carte des des des précipitations là
mondial il y a certains endroits en fait
les endroits qui sont déjà arid en
général en règ du P là ok les endroits
où il y a déjà de l'eau va en avoir un
petit peu plus et les endroits qui sont
déjà rid vont en avoir un peu moin moin
ce qui fait qu'il y a plein d'endroits
comme ça en fait qui sont déjà habitués
à gérer une quantité d'eau minimale mais
ilé tu peux pas gérer pas d'eau c'est ça
ce qui fait qu'en gros les endroits qui
sont déjà à Rê déserti on de fortes
probabilités d'avoir plus de problèmes
mais on peut penser par exemple au
bassin méditerranéen où il y a plein
plein plein de gens autour de ça et
c'est un endroit où il va avoir des
vagues de chaleur et une diminution des
précipitations de façon générale donc ça
devient un endroit problématique on sait
à quel point c'est explosif comme
territoire sans faire de mauvais je de
mot là mais c'est ça là tu sais c'est
puis est-ce que la sécheresse c'est le
le le
le la sous-branche des changements
climatiques la plus euh la plus dans
l'immédiat euh pas dangereuse mais
alarmante ou c'est le dans le monde pour
la sécurité alimentaire c'est c'est un
des plus important probablement ça puis
les le le niveau de la mer les l'érosion
les surcotes
ça aussi c'est dans dans les deux qui
restent de les plus extrêmes donc
TR en terme de de niveau de la mer
est-ce que est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est quantifié ça le oui on le sait le
com
question monter c'est quantifié mais on
est dans des projections donc encore une
fois basé sur des hypothèses d'émission
de gaz donc a une fourchette la tendance
connait après ça va aller de quoi à quoi
a il a quand même une marge je comprends
mais ça
oui je suis pas bonne pour me rappeler
des chiffres fait que c'est une coupe de
dizaines de centimètres vingtaine de
ctimè c'est ça mais sont ben là est-ce
que vous voulez déjà qu'on se projette
dans le futur on peut commencer
tranquillement on ok non non mais c'est
ça on va prendre la référence de 2100
parce c'est souvent ce qui est utilisé
là c'est encore ça dépend beaucoup des
émissions mais on peut aller jusqu'à par
exemple 1 MRE d'augmentation d' au
niveau de la mer ok mais euh c'est pas
bon pour New York là par exemple oui ben
non c'est pas bon là mais je veux dire
moi je serais plus inquiète pour le
bangladesch par
ex non c'est ça mais ça les Madeleine ou
c'est ça ouais c'est ça euh oui tout
c'est ça il y a des endroits qui sont
pires que d'autres pour d'autres raisons
le soulèvement ézostatique par les
continents sont encore en train de se
soulever avec la fondte des glaces du la
dernière GL OK et ce
est la ba c'est encore en train de
soulever ce qui fait dans certaines
régions du monde c'est pas un enjeu pour
l'instant mais je m'gard un petit peu ok
si on revient donc auement du de la mer
on peut dire en moyenne à peu près 1 m
la fin du siècle mais ce qui se passe
c'est que ça arrêtera pas en
200 et il y a
une anxiété je je met le bouton d'alerte
okutre des c'est ça euh tant que le
comment dire qu' a pas des points de
rupture de fonte des NIS de de de de de
glacier là tu sais que le groslin font
pas que l'Antarctique font pas c'est
encore contrôlable mais si on atteignait
un niveau de réchauffement faisant en
sorte que par exemple Gren l fond là
c'est 6 m de plus ok mais ça ça arrivera
pas en 2100 et les probabilités sont
faibles mais il y a des événements comme
ça un peu catastrophe qui peuvent se
produire dans des simulations qui sont
hautement improbables mais à conséquence
majeure et là on rentre dans vraiment on
change complètement le visage la planète
là ok des des des pays qui disparaiss
pratiquement à 6 m oui oui ou oui c'est
beau c'est c'est c'est énorme ça c'est
la fond de Grenade mais comme je dis on
n'est pas rendu là on pourrait peut-être
retomber dans quelque chose de moins
catastrophique mettons pour lancer le le
la discussion sur les projections puis
sur le futur tout à l'heure tu as
mentionn que si on arrêtait maintenant
on a quand même des projections sur
qu'est-ce que se passe si demain matin
on ferme la valve des gaz infiter puis
qui qu'on arrête là genre que le
problème est réglé ben pas le problème
est réglé mais rien on aimit plus rien
là demain matin tout le monde est
carbone neutre tout le monde est
végétalien il y a plus de voitures sur
les routes on marche au travail tout le
monde habite dans une ville de 15
minutes avec un un jardin sur leur toit
là tu sais panneau sal fait tout est
fermé demain matin c'est quoi qui se
passe OK mais en gros on reste à peu
près à l'équilibre ouais ok euh là
encore une fois je suis vraiment pas
bonne pour les chiffres a exactement les
nombres je on on va te faire confiance
que que tu tu parles pas à travers ton
chapeau ouais ouais c'est ça mais en
gros c'est ça c'est qu'on reste encore
un petit un petit réchauffement un petit
peu mais on reste à peu près à
l'équilibre donc on revient on retourne
pas où on était avant il y a pas de
retour en arrière avec cette méthode
avec avec un arrêt complet il y a pas de
retour en AR mais non parce que les
émissions sont encore là ok ce qui est
vraiment c'est juste ça reste à peu près
à l'équilibre simplement c'est c'est
c'est ça ouais est-ce que on reste comme
on est là dans le fond oui c'est se
nouvel état d'équilibre c'est que la
Terre a rééquilibré son bilan radiatif
pour retomber au point de vue neutre
donc elle a simplement augmenté un petit
peu sa température pour absorber le
rayonnement supplémentaire qui provient
de l'augmentation des gaz eff dans la
dans l'atmosphère donc si on arrête
d'émettre la la terre se régénère pas
d'elle-même se régule pas là non mais on
revient pas on va pas avec le temps
revenir en arrière c'est comme pas
perdre le le degré gagné là ok il y a
puis ça il y a il y a aucun moyen o ça
prendrait des des des déploement
technologique
complètement je juste jeis juste garder
je
juste si la réponse c'est oui non mais
non parce que j'ai l'impression que
c'est un podcast qui va quand même
possiblement créer de l'anxiété s'il y a
des des avenus positives et comme
émergent je les garderai peut-être pour
la fin OK je sais pas là mais il y en a
oui oui comme je les demandé moi il y a
quand même pas des bonnes nouvelles mais
il y a des nouvelles qui sont moins
anxyogènes qu' on été dans le passé
quand même gardons les bonnes nouvelles
pour la fin là fait que si à place de
tirer la champlure d'arrêter maintenant
on continue dans la trajectoire qu'on a
actuellement ça ressemble à quoi le
futur
euh ben disons que à peu près 3 degrés
de changement à la fin en 200 toujours
laférence 200 àort pr si on n'aimait pas
plus ni pas moins c'est trop si ouais si
on respecte les engagements
oui exactement si on respecte les
engagements donc puis ça c'est ça veut
dire une
réduction ça veut dire une réduction des
émissions pas une réductionment de la
concentration parce qu'on aimait quand
même mais oui et bon c'est ça voyz pu ça
c'est c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle parce qu'on le voit les on vous
parle de trajectoire de scénari
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre on le
voit si si on continue à si on fait rien
s'il y a pas de politique en place on
voit que c'est beaucoup plus que 3
degrés donc on voit qu'il y a un eff
fait des politiques des engagements en
place est-ce que ça ass non mais il y a
quand même la bonne nouvelle c'est que
les les gens les les politiens les
gouvernements à haut niveau sont en
train de mettre en place des politiques
qui font une réelle différence sur les
changements climatiques qui s'en
viennent h ok 3 degrés c'est c'est trop
encore mais moins que 5 et
6 ok VO 5 et 6 m mettons qu'on commence
par le scénario catastrophe mett si on
faisait si on continue d'émettre autant
sinon plus on on on attendrait 5 et 6
c'est 2100 puis en plus 2100 comme on
disait c'est pas ouis mais ça commence à
être difficile d'atteindre 5 et 6
honnêtement là ok on sera pas là bah tu
sais en on parle toujours de 2100 c'est
sû que on y arriverait un moment donné
si on arrête pas des mettre là mais il
faut presque faut le vouloir là pour
atteindre ces ouais c'est changement là
5 et 6 ça veut dire quoi là on a parlé
de des niveau de la mer qui montrait de
5 6 M peut-être euh non pas en 200 c'est
juste que ça pourrait déclencher
éventuellement peut-être quelque chose
mais en 200 on parle d' 1 m à ce momentl
là oui ou ou sinon c'est quoi les autres
effets là c'est comme c'est comment que
la la la terre changerait ben euh tu
peux t'imaginer ce qu'il y a maintenant
tout ce qu'on entend parler un petit peu
les feux de forêt la disparition de la
neige c'est les plusu intenses en été
des grandes périodes de sécheresse mais
tout plus prononcé parce qu'en gros le
changement
climatique de premier ordre il est
linéaire ok autrement dit plus ton ton
changement moyen est euh est élevé plus
tes changements vont être prononcés mais
de manière juste ton patron devient plus
certain si on peut dire ok euh donc
c'est ça vraiment c'est tout ce qu'on
connaît maintenant mais plus fort h HM
en gros sais c'est c'est ça mais c'est
clair que 5°gr ben tu sais euh si on
parle à l'hiver ben ça veut dire que en
fait on regarde même plus les
changements à 5 6 degrés pour être honnê
parce c'est rendu h de
on peut le faire pour étudier des
changements possibles catastrophiques
mais c'est plus ça qui est réaliste je
et comme on s'intéresse beaucoup à ce
qui peut être utilisé pour l'adaptation
mais on regarde plus des changements
réalistes mais comme je dis à ce momentl
tu fa imaginer des des vagues de chaleur
qui au lieu de durer quelques jours vont
durer un mois qui vont avoir au lieu
d'atteindre un certain nombre de degrés
vont atteindre 10 degrés de plus c'est
l'hiver qui va pas disparaître mais tu
sais la neige moyenne dans le sud du
Québec il y en a plus tu sais ce genre
de choses là des périodes étiage intense
ça h puis le le le
scénario qu'on pense si on atteint nos
cibles de 3 degrés en
2100 le ministre guilbau était assez à
votre à votre place pas plus tard que
vendredi puis si je me rappelle bien d'
corrigement si je me trompe il disait
qu'un scénario optimiste était en 2050
lui je pense que c'était 2050 qui qui
mettait son sa date c'était de 1.5 degr
est-ce que ça ça fait du sens selon les
projections que vous avez ben ça se peut
1.5 en 2050 mais ça veut quand même dire
à ce moment-là à peu près 2 et demi 3
ouis il semble qu' a parlé 2 degrés me
semble qu' a parlé de 2 degr scénario
optimiste il disait 2 degrés c'est
probablement ce qui va arriver puis lui
il parle un scénario optimiste ça doit
être 200 dans ce non non sont quand même
généralement sur du du du
2050 c'est plus optimiste que not 3 degr
donc ouais eux sont sont encore dans une
optique où ils vont réussir à atteindre
la carboneutralité en 2050 puis les
politiques en place vont être plus
sévères qu' ce de que ce qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui là donc on a du chemin à
faire pour pour arriver là c'est ça
ouais ouais c'est ça puis dans ce
scénario là qui est probablement le
scénario le plus plausible qu'on se
rendre à 3 degrés qu'on qu'on essaie
d'atteindre nos cibles en terme
d'adaptation
qu'est-ce que ça représente qu'est-ce
qui gen question large ouais question
très très l mant qu'on essaie la
déconstruire en plusieurs sous sous
catégories m
mais j'ai pas de piste dans fais ok
essayons ouais ouais par exemple l'été
on a parlé des vagues de chaleur des
journées aus de 30°gr dans un monde dans
une des municipalités où on a très peu
d'espace vert
on a très peu de climatisation on est
dans un monde où là si on est à 30 jours
auudessus de 30°grés pendant un été on
est habitué à 5 6 jours on s'en va à
presque un mois 30°grés les nuits sont
très chaudes les gens sont mal adaptés
nos infrastructures sont mal adaptées
nos hpitaau sont mal adaptés donc il
faut commencer ça commence beaucoup par
l'aménagement du territoire peu importe
peu importe l'aléa ou le climat
changement que ça soit les les vagues de
chaleur la les les feux de forêts les
inondations l'érosion conser ça ça passe
beaucoup par un meilleur aménagement de
notre territoire pour pour essayer de
renforcer la résilience dans les
municipalités pour les vages de chaleur
c'est mettre du vert la climatisation ça
va en prendre c'est pas nécessairement
la solution qu'on veuton on contrib
c'est ça bon malgré qu'on a de l'énergie
renouvelable renouvelable chez
nous ok attendez un petit peu c'est quoi
ce regard là l'énergie renouvelable est
pas c'est pas d'énergie verte à 100 %
ouou oui non mais c'est parce qu' encore
bon encore une fois ok je oui merci ça
non mais c'est parce que il va avoir des
besoins croissants en électricité mais
c'est parce que aménager arnacher des
rivières aménager des barrages il y a
quand même un un coût environnemental à
ça dans ce sensl il y a aucune énergie
qui a zéro coût environnemental dans ça
mais comme au Québec on a quand même
arnâcher les rivières les plus près que
ça commence à être faut aller chercher
cvental qui qui qui est plus important
planter des vings sur les buildings de
béton c'est les solutions basé sur la
nature on essaie de se tourner davantage
vers du vert que du béton que du gris
que de la climatisation mais et les
demandes en énergie comme demque le dit
vont changer plus en été nos nos
infrastructures sont pas adaptées à ça
moins en hiver les HIV vont être plus
doux on va avoir besoin de moins de de
moins chauffé en hiver l'érosion côtière
çaen est peut-être un autre dans dans du
pays on le voit déjà donc comment est-ce
qu'on aménage mieux puis l' on va devoir
probablement prendre des décisions
difficiles pour le moment on a fait des
belles choses en aménagement de du
territoire en re
re refaisant des plages comme à Persé ça
ça fonctionne super bien mais il y a une
limite à un moment donné à certains
endroits certains trait cô où là les
gens sont on va se le dire très très
près de la côteou les routes les rails
donc on commence déjà au Québec à
réfléchir à la relocalisation de
certaines de nos infrastructures c'est
pas une conversation qui est super
facile que les gens veulent avoir
nécessairement mais c'est c'est le genre
de de décision difficile
qu'éventuellement va peut-être falloir
prendre selon ce qui s'en vient dans le
climat futur mettons par rapport à
l'érosion c'est quoi les je parlais
Madeline tantôt je pense que c'est
un très à risque moi mes parents il ont
habité là longtemps
je jeis né là tu sais puis euh le les a
Madeleine déjà de mon enfance et
d'aujourd'hui ça ça a changé là tu sais
puis je pense que c'est puis tu merig
vous me corrigez si je me trompe du
surtout à la fonte des des glaces qui
protégeit qui
protégeit les côtes de l'érosion
euh c'est quoi les les endroits les plus
Aris tu parlais de au Québec mettons au
Québec tout toute la côte les les comme
tu dis les îles de Madeleine mais la la
côte au complet de de la
Gaspésie pas jusqu'au bas Saint-Laurent
mais côte nord toute la péninsule je
veux dire c'est des c'est des endroit où
justement les gens c'est pas juste que
c'est le climat c'est qu'on a déjà une
vulnérabilité qui qui est installé on on
a bâti en s'adaptant à un climat passé
en en se disant que les choses allaient
pas changer donc on est vulnérable de
par la façon qu'on a construit donc ça
ça ça ça nous aide pas on a besoin de
travailler sur le climat mais on a aussi
besoin de travailler sur la la façon
qu'on utilise euh le territoire h mais
naturellement les humains ont on on
s'installe toujours près près des côes
près de l'eau j'ai
l'IM c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'il a
des politiques ou des directives qui
c'est pas une conversation facile ni
agréable puis vous quand vous avez le
mandat par exemple de de de de proposer
d'aller voir les les preneurs de
décisions avec ces problématiques là
qu'est-ce que vous leur amener proposé
nous on va beaucoup faire des études
justement pour évaluer les coûts de on
fait rien versus les coûts de plusieurs
différentes solutions donc comme je vous
disais là à perc par exemple on a mis
c'est une recherche de plage ils ont
remis des galets mais avant de faire ça
ils ont évalué une dizaine d'autres
options il y avait toutes sortes de un
mur de béton et des solutions il y en
avait beaucoup la la la moins cûeur
c'était pas nécessairement la plage de
galet mais celle qui allait durer le
plus longtemps donc c'est c'est c'est un
accompagnement de longue haleine avec
les gens qui prennent des décisions pour
justement évaluer toutes les options de
réfléchir à court moyen long terme parce
que on parle beaucoup de ce qui s'en
vient mais on sait de manière générale
il y a des études qui sont fait sur une
plus large échelle puis on sait que si
on met on investit un dollar dans
l'adaptation changement climatique on
sauve 10 à 15 dollars en cou éviter de
manière générale la règle du PCE c'est
10 à 15 15 oui
ouais donc ça c'est c'est énorme ça
c'est de manière générale c'est la règle
du pousse après ça dépend de l'enjeu ça
dépend où on est ça dépend de plein de
choses mais on sait partout dans le
monde c'est à peu près la même chose on
sait que c'est mieux de prévenir de se
préparer que de rapicer à la pièce quand
ça se produit puis de rien faire 10 à 15
fois c'est massif là ça c'est énorme si
c'est pas un argument euh pour un
gouvernement je sais pas c'est quoi qui
estun argument faut mettre l'argent
ouais là faut mettre c'est ça l'ffaire
c'est ça l'ffaire c'est faut le mettre
c'est juste que l'argent de maintenant
dans plus dans le futur c'est pas dans 4
an tu dis autre partie va éc peut-être
mon adversaire va économiser exactement
j'avoue hein c'est ouais ouis que ce
soit c'est ça que ce soit indépendant
genre une espèce de gestion des finance
publ indépend genre de dictature mais
par quelqu'un de
bon dictat
éclair ouais oua a c'est c'est fou c'est
fou parlons maintenant des avenue de de
bonnes nouvell plus ouais est-ce que
tantôt on parlait projection sur tirer
la tirer la la champlure est-ce qu'il y
a un retour en arrière possible est-ce
que il y a est-ce que la les avancées
technologique peuvent on peut projeter
un monde dans lequel on on retrouve
TER on retire ouais ben la bon sais la
terre en santé je pense que il y a une
question qui est plus large que juste
les changements climatique là je pense
que c'est plus l'utilisation des
ressources mais bon on est
d'accord l'être humain reste l'êtreoui
c'est ça oui c'est ça mais c'est clair
qu' un développement technologique qui
peut vraiment nous aider beaucoup il y a
des choses qui sont déjà testées à
petite échelle la capture de carbone
donc on retire du carbone l'atmosphère
souvent pour l'enfouir de différentes
façons euh c'est fait à petite échelle
et d'après mes connaissances comme je
suis pas une spécialiste de ça mais ça à
petite échelle ça fonctionne
relativement bien le problème c'est
quand on essaie de d'y aller à plus
grande échelle à ce moment-là la le le
le le besoin en énergie pour faire ça
donc les coûts aussi financiers pour
faire ça euh deviennent faramineux ce
qui fait que ce n'est plus rentable si
tu dépenses plus
d'énergie finalement tu prod plus de gaz
à effet de serre selon la façon dont ton
énergie est produite pour retirer des
gaz à effet de ser ben ça bon on
s'entend que ça ça fonctionne pas mais
donc le développement de ces
technologies là qui on espère va se
produire bientôt à plus grande échelle
va vraiment permettre de retirer du
carbone de l'atmosphère OK et
là cette technologie là existe ou existe
pas encore existe ce sont à petite
échelle ok le problème c'est vraiment
quand on passe une échelle macro parce
que
négligable parce que c'est pas seulement
le fait de capter le carbone qui serait
émis par des industrie sera vraiment
d'en retirer de de de l'atmosphère euh
c'est ça donc de de de le remettre en
sous-formme solide si on veut ou sais
ouais j'avoue que je stocker ça quelque
part on le remett en dessous de la
terre mais il y a beaucoup des des
scénarios d'émission du futur qui qui
tiennent compte de ces futurs
développements technologiques là ok donc
pour vraiment
si comment dire comment je pourrais dire
ça ok euh donc on revient à notre type
de 3°gr celus oui c'est en fonction des
politiques euh mais il faudrait aussi
que ces technologies là soit efficace et
adapté à grande échelle c'est calculé
c'est oui ça fait partie des scénarios
d'émission qu'on utilise dans les
modèles tout parce que le le le le J
considère que ces technologiesl vont
être disponibles OK euh donc oui il y a
quelque chose qui dépend de la
technologie qui va venir nous aider euh
là j'avoue que si on retire plus de
carbone dans l'atmosphère que-ce qu'on
avait par exemple auparavant je je sais
pas trop ce que ça va donner je suis pas
certaine qu'il y a des expériences qui
ont été faites là-dessus donc si par
exemple on on retirait tellement de
carbone dans l'atmosphère qu'on
retombait à un un niveau par exemple
préindustriel est-ce qu'on retournerait
euh à ce climatlà probablement tant
qu'il y a pas de point de rupture qui
ont été franchis par exemple si le Gren
est fondu ben euh on pourra pas le
rebâtir comme ça mais si on prend par
exemple la glace de mer il suffit d'un
hiver froid puis la glace de mer en
Arctique ou dans le golf va revenir là
tu sais donc tant que il y a pas de de
vraiment c'est ça comme je dis points de
rupture qui ont été atteint euh c'est
puis les points de rupture bon la fond
du Grenland euh la la la la la
disparition de l'Amazone dans le sens
que de l'Amazonie pardon pas de la
rivière mais de si toutes les forêts euh
meurent pour différentes raisons en
Amazonie ben ça c'est c'est des points
de rupture là parce que ça reviendra pas
ça c'est ça mais si ça y a aucun point
de rupture qui est atteint on devrait
retourner a priori c'est ce que je
dirais c'est quoi les excuse juste sur
les points de rupture dans le fond il y
a c'est il y en A- d'autres c'est quoi
en fait tu parlais de c'est les grandes
forêts disparaissent si les glaciers
fondent il y a-tu d'autres variables qui
pe être catastrophiqu attends minute
faudrait que je les volans de la planète
ben les volcans c'est autre chose c'est
vol c'est c'est ils font ils font le
petite affairire il y a pas de
changement climatique mais c'est sûr que
quand une éruption volcanique ça ça
diminue la température pour une année ou
deux là mais c'est ça fait si on fait
sauter toutes les Volcanes exactement on
va se tomber l'équivalent d'un hiivver
nucléaire là mais c'est çaou on l' vu un
peu avec la covid avec la covid il y
avait plus les gens étaient pris à la
maison puis y a eu une baisse
instantanée ça remoné très rou PRS 10 %
des émissions ouis on est descendu à 10
% ba non il y a une baisse de 10 % en
total ce qui B il aurait fallu faudrait
faire ça à chaque année ouais ah le
monde très près là
ou voici la
solution mieae mieux faire faire tout
les
volcans je pense que si un sondage à la
population ce serait ça le gang ouais
mais mettons de de
de 30 ans de carrière de projection là
est-ce que parce que là on parle la
technologie qu'on prend en compte
maintenant dans les projections mais
est-ce que
maintenant on on prend en compte une
technologie que on était pas capable de
même imaginer
avant au sens où les projections dans
pere 10 ans vont est-ce est-ce qu'il y a
des chances les projections 10ans a pas
prévu une avenue qu'on qu'on peut pas
prévoir maintenant j'imagine mais au
point de vue développement technologique
c'est sûr que oui mais a priori toutes
les composantes dans les scénarios
d'émission qui sont fait par le par le
GC par
l'ONU par rapport au développement
développement techque technologique par
aux ententes entre gouvernement pour les
réduction d'émissions par rapport au
développement de la population
l'utilisation des sols il y a quand même
plusieurs scénarios qui sont élaborés
qui suivent les dernières les dernières
recherches vraiment les plus à jour
c'est élaboré par des des grandes
équipes là ce qui fait oui au point de
vue technologique il peut arriver
quelque chose mais en général il y a
quand même un certain
indice on sait à peu près où ça où ça
s'en va ce qu'on sait pas c'est à quelle
vitesse ça va à quel point les
investissements vont euh vont se
produire donc évident que sil y a plus
d'investissement dans un certain type de
recherche ben en général le
développement technologique à grande
échelle se produit plus rapidement c'est
plus à ce niveau-là mais il y a à peu
près tout ça qui est pris en compte
c'est pour ça qu'on se retrouve avec une
grande famille possible de scénarios
d'émission euh c'est ça ou ouais c'est
c'est ce qui explique la la la
fourchette qu'on par exactement c'est ça
ou oui puis là ce qu'on ce qu'on a parlé
c'est beaucoup la fourchette de ce qui
est possible mais ce qu'on peut simuler
je dire il y a des changements qui sont
encore plus grands sauf qu'en général on
essaie de se concentrer pour
l'adaptation pour des choses qui sont
réalistes mais on peut faire des
simulation catastrophe ou avec aucun
changement tant qu'on veut puis mais toi
en trant carrière aujourd'hui tu es plus
optimiste qu'il y a 30 ans ou il y a 30
ans jeis sûrement trop naïve pour être
c'est ça mais globalement oui par
rapport à A 10 ans c'est clair que oui
parce que comme je disais il y avait ça
faisait quand même on va dire 20 ans que
je ou et il y avait rien qui changeait
je veux dire honnêtement là au niveau
mondial tu dis écoute ça fait des années
puis moi ça fait 30 ans mais comme je
les premiers rapports du JX ça remonte
tu sais avant ça quand j'ai commencé ma
maîtrise mon prof il m'a dit mon
directeur m'a dit ok les humains mettent
des gaz à effet de on change le climat
tu sa cétait déjà clair là tu sais et
pourtant ça tu sais il y a 10 ans c'est
comme il y avait aucun effort au point
de vue gouvernemental j'ai l'impression
qu'il se passait rien chaque 6 7 ans 8
ans il un rapport du GX on fait on sort
toutes nos belles données données
scientifiques mais après ça il se passe
quoi rien il y a une COP où il y a des
gens qui parlent ou ils vont tous en
avion puis finalement après ils font des
cibles des objectifs qui remplissent pas
qui suivent pas qui respectent pas alors
que là j'ai l'impression qu'il y a autre
chose depuis 10 ans vous vous sentez
plus écouté oui mais globalement au
niveau mondial on a l'impression qu'il
se passe quelque chose un petit peu plus
à la fois en atténuation puis en
adaptation moi je le vois aussi je
travaille davantage sur le côté
adaptation avec les gens sur le terrain
puis les gens sont
davantage conscientiser puis on voit une
une mouvance vers ok on doit se
mobiliser on doit agir on doit se
préparer au négatif et prendre prendre
les opportunités qui passent aussi comme
on disait on se compare on se console il
y a des choses qui peuvent euh profiter
au au à certains secteurs au Québec
aussi mais ça on le voit nous aussi en
adaptation que les les gens sont
davantage prêt à agir prêt à écouter
puis à se préparer à cette fourchette là
justement deavant cétait bon sa pas là
vous nous dites ça va être en ça et ça
on peut pas prendre de décision mais
vous en prenez déjà des décisions sur
tout tout est incertain en vie là je
dire donc vous prenez déjà des décisions
sur des trucs qui sont incertains puis
là on voit
que ça c'est c'est mieux compris pu il y
a une volonté d'agir qui qui était pas
là auparavant puis ouais puis l'effort
il est il est mondial ou quand des fois
qu'onarde ailleurs parce que tu sais on
diress souvent quand qu'on parle
environnement il y a toujours euh une
langue salle qui va dire oui mais on
bout nous autres faire des efforts si
l'autre à côté il pollue ça sert à rien
puis c'est un affaire mondiale puis tu
sais évidemment si tout le monde passe
de même on on bouge pas on avance pas
mais est-ce que est-ce que tout le monde
fait un effort ou
ben toujours des moutons noir là ok
c'est mais globalement oui tout le monde
fait un effort on a juste à le voir avec
le développement ben de l'énergie verte
de l'éolien et du solaire principalement
au cours des dernières années là c'est
c'est c'est fantastique là euh c'est ça
et oui tout le monde a des des des cies
de réduction il y a certains endroits
qu's ont atteint il y a d'autres
endroits c'est plus difficile évidemment
ça va et ça vient avec les gouvernements
c'est on s'entend que si on s'en va vers
des gouvernements bon plusservateur pour
tu utiliser ce lié à rien du tout ex non
c'est ça c'est clair que ça risque
d'être plus difficile tu sais B et ça
c'est ce qui fait aussi que ça retarde
aussi dans dans dans certains cas mais
oui le le mouvement tout le monde est
affecté là je pense que il y a pas un
pays sur la planète qui peut dire ah moi
ça me touche pas c'est pas pour rien que
justement dans les au niveau des cops ou
quand il y a des des rapports du J qui
sont publiés c'est vraiment c'est un
effort mondial ouais et cet effort
mondial là a débuté dans les 10
dernières années euh à cause de quoi
grâce à quoi ben il non il a débuté
avant mais je te dirais que c'était
peut-être plus on a laisse B écoute
c'est vraimentinon personnel encore une
fois je suis m B làdans on allait se
faire voir à la C pour dire que c'est
important mais dans le fond on pren
aucune action après là pourquoi je pense
que parce que les effets se font sentir
parce que les gens peuvent plus dire oh
ben non justement il y a déjà fait chaud
dans le passé donc c'est normal y a
tellement d'événements on a les données
les coû sont faramineux pour les
gouvernements quand ça commence à
réellement coûter cher quand que c'est
quand on se fait dire ça va coûter cher
c'est comme ok le problème pas de suite
mais là quand ça coûte
cher ou plus là peut on est passé d'un
problème théorique à un problème concret
ouais fait que je pense que c'est pour
ça et aussi parce que faut que la
population pousse c'est toujours des
gouvernements c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est élu en pas partout là mais en
général euh c'est ça ce qui fait que si
la population pousse et ça il y a une
conscientisation chez les plus jeunes
qui est extraordinaire
là fait que ça est-ce que est-ce que
pour le fun fait des projections passé
200 ou ben c'est c'est vraiment ça la
l'espèce de
de standard puis que on mesure jusqu'à
2100 mais c'est le standard ok mais moi
depuis que j'ai commencé c'est le
standard ok donc
éventuellementou par que là il y a plein
de gens qui sont nés en ce moment qui
vont être encore en vie en 20100is c'est
plus un un
loin nous on se le fait demander
davantage parce que justement tu constru
une infrastructure un barrage dans le
Nord pour pas pour pas le dire mais des
des infrastructures massives dans 100
ans il faut qu'elle soit encore là dans
150 ans il faut qu'elle soit encore là
donc on se fait de plus en plus demander
ouais c'est quoi la vision c'est quoi la
vision long terme plus loin que mais le
le le problème c'est comme les scénarios
ben qu'on appelle scénario d'émission
son les scénarios socio-économiques on
va dire là dépendent justement de du
développement social et du développement
économique donc de la démographie euh de
toutes les ententes ça devient difficile
de se projeter euh plus loin ce qui se
passe c'est que il y a on remte àm il y
a 20 il y a 30 ans on on utilisait juste
des émissions de gaz à effet souvent
théorique au départ on double c'est 1 %
d'augmentation donc il y avait pas la
composante alors que maintenant elle est
présente donc ça vient plus difficile de
de dépasser 2100 sans tomber dans des
hypothèses qui vont peut-être avoir
aucun lien avec la réalité sais le nuU
fait des projections démographiques mais
si on n pas de projection démographique
dépassé 200 on peut pas associer des
émissions à ça puis c'est de c'est une
des diff h ouais à quoi ça ressemble les
projections démographiques justement oh
il y a plein de scénarios là euh écoute
il y en a ça augmente jusqu'en 250 ça
dimin il y en a d'autres c'est mais
souvent c'est bah ce qui semble ouais
peut-être le plus c'est que ça augmente
pu qui m'amené ça ça stabilise ouais
ouais ça sera pas infiniment euh
exponentiellement en croissance là comme
ça l'a été dans 50 dernières années
difficile à dire écoute
c'est quoi le max quoi
10 milliards 20 milliards le maximum
ouais c'est ça je sais pas faut mais je
pense que ça doit-êre c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut prendre en compte dans
dans les projections euh environnemental
oui exactement pour associer ben il faut
associer des concentrations des
émissions de gaz effet ser quelque chose
sa tu peux pas j dire ça augmente on l'a
déjà fait dans le passé parce qu'on
avait pas cet appui là mais maintenant
c'est plus sa on est rendu plus loin que
ça là fait que puis il faut être
conscient aussi en tant que qu'espèce
que il y
a il y a une limite à au nombre d'humain
qu' peut avoir sur la planète en terme
de ressources puis tout ça tu sais oui
mais il peut en avoir plus à certains
endroits puis moins à d'autres comme ça
ououais exact
exact combien ça aimet un humain jusqu'à
18 ans ça dépend tu habites où ici
mettons on est à combien 7 tonnes par
année je crois à peu près parce que je
me y a mois je
pense 7 tonnes par année ouais
l'équivalent CO2 mais dans certains pays
dans le monde si à un c'est beau là on
aim on aimit beaucoup là c'est clair
qu'on aimit beaucoup là mais un de par
notre nordicité c'est clair que on
dépense beaucoup d'énergie pour ouais
c'est ça puis notre notre oui justement
le déplacement et notre notre façon de
vivre simplement ou 7 tonnes par année
il me semble ou de
mémoireou puis le 3 degrés d'ici
20100 parce que mais tu sais dans est-ce
que est-ce que après ça on estime que
justement pour la suite parce que il
veut en avoir une suite est-ce que
est-ce que le but c'est que ça reste là
ou on sait que ça va continuer de monter
dans sens dans le sens que-ce qu'on
serait capable à partir de en 200 par
exemple de d'être complètement carbone
neutre puis é mettre ouais moi je pense
que oui au point de vue technologique je
pense que c'est clair qu'on va arriver
là là donc après ça ça reviendra à ce
qu'on disait tantôt de comme
ou fait ça à quoi ça ressemble à tro
comme société ben si jamais on a la
chance d'avoir un peu de neige tu sors
tes skis rapido puis tu y vas au Québec
3 degr c'est 6 degr là dans le sud du
Québec c'est plus que 9 beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup donc c'est ça pour le
Québec là c'est pas trop c'est c'est oui
c'est le double c'est 40 de en
été oui pendant toute l'été ouais c'est
des gros changements horri qu oui oui
oui oui c'est horrible comment
oua ouais puis c'est pas le Québec dans
lequel j'ai grandi là il y a plus de de
caban à suc parce que les érables il va
en avoir m plus au
N il y a des érables ça va coûter
cher oui ou ouais ouais plé tu sais
exemple la forêt tu sais le la forêt
béale est adaptée jeux dire elle existe
à cause du climat puis euh
si si si la température augmente est-ce
que ces Abes font juste mourir à ca en
fait parce que il va avoir ce qu'on
appelle des accidents de régénération
les les les espèces qu'on a dans la
forêt boréale sont habitués ont besoin
des feux les cocottes ouvrent pas s'il y
a pas de feux mais sont habitués à une
certaine fréquence donc ça prend un
armature qui a produit des cocottes avec
des graines matures pour que ça ouvre si
tu as des feux trop fréquents oublie ça
la forêt peut pas se régénérer donc là
faut que tu replantes puis là ça coûter
cher puis donc il y a une limite à
l'adaptation de nos forêts à une
fréquence de feu qui qui est en
augmentation puis des des territoires
qui sont de plus en plus grands on parle
de superficies qui sont aussi en en
augmentation avec les changements
climatiques donc ça demande une
adaptabilité de gestion de nos
forêtsicité à combattre les feux puis ça
fait partie de ouaisà ouais puis puis
donc c'est ça puis j'ine qu'au nord du
Québec c'est encore plus grand
l'augmentation en terme de changement
changement déjà la limite nordique des
arbres a déjà migré de façon importante
dans les dernières années puis on le
voit de plus en plus donc comme
Dominique a dit on voit les les
écosystèmes migrent vers le nord donc ça
va pas aussi vite les arbres on des
pattes il peuvent pas seever puis
déplacer avec les changements
climatiques mais tranquillement la la la
forêt bouge tranquillement mais on voit
la FA ex ça c'est plus rapide voilà puis
on a des espèces du Nord qui descendent
plus le sud on a des croisements qu'on
avait jamais vu avant le renard rou puis
le renard qui comm qui commence à se
rencontrer est-ce que j'ai vu un grizzly
puis un polaire j'ai vu ça sur
intern
ch je suis encore là je suis encore là
pour en
parler mais ouais c'est ça il y avait eu
comme un
croisementou c'est ça donc nous on voit
venir ce qui est aux États-Unis donc ça
dans les bonnes nouvelles c'est qu'on a
quand même une vision de ce qui s'en
vient un petit peu on peut regarder chez
nos amis du Sud puis dire ok qu'est-ce
qui se passe là qu'est-ce qu' sont en
train de faire eux en terme d'adaptation
il ont une longueur d'avance puis on
peut en profiter de cette longueur
d'avance là parce qu'ils ont testé des
chose puis on peut aller un petit peu
plus vite dans notre dans notre
adaptation changement climatique h les
gens par exemple qui vivent au nord du
Québec de manière plus ancestrale si on
veut c'est c'est c'est un mode de vie
qui c'est un mode de vie qui va exa oua
mais en même temps faut quand même tu
sais il va quand même encore faire froid
au nord du Québec en 200 ok il faut pas
s'imaginer que c'est ça mais il fait
moins froid donc ce qui est basé comme
on mentionnait au tout début c'est les
routes de glace tout ce qui par rapport
à les infrastructures sur le Perger le
sol ça c'est plus viable
saisou de ce que je comprends dans le
fond c'est que si on continue dans la
direction qu'on va en terme de réduction
ben on a une bonne idée de ce à quoi il
faut se préparer dans le fond ou fait
qu'on a une bonne idée de pouvoir de on
peut mettre quand même sur papier assez
de façon assez précise qu'est-ce qui
s'en vient puis comment on peut le gérer
là com ou oui ben de façon globale c'est
sûr que si tu vas dans le détail ou dans
là à ce momentl ça demande plein parce
ça touche tellement à tout oui on a une
idée ouais général mais c'est ça ouais
ouaisou vas-y vas-y non non mais
j'allais dire agriculture je veux dire
le nombre de fermes le nombre de culture
est infini on sait à peu près ce qui
s'en vient mais après pour donner les
bonnes mesures à la bonne ferme mais là
ça prend des études plus précises pour
comprendre sur cette parcelleel
qu'est-ce qui se passe comment ils
peuvent adapt puis ça c'est vrai un peu
partout là ça ça prend quand même des
une une des études ou une information
qui est plus locale pour être capable de
bien mettre en place l'adaptation puis
l'adaptation on parle souvent
d'adaptation de bouquet de mesure c'est
pas une mesure qui va régler toutes nos
problèmes puis les les les enjeux sont
toutes liés si on parle par exemple de
gestion de l'eau l'eau dans les cours
d'eau c'est les municipalités c'est les
agriculteurs c'est le tourisme c'est
plein plein plein plein de monde si
chacun de ces secteurs là décide de
mettre sa mesure d'adaptation en place
peut facilement nuuir aux autres donc
c'est ça la complexité aussi c'est un
effort
coordonné que que ça prend ça complex un
peu comme tu dis les solutions les
connaît mais là on les connaît à la
pièce faut les mettre faut assembler le
le cast puis s'assurer que tout fit à
différentes échelles h puis est-ce que
on parlait de on voit qu'est-ce qui s'en
vient aux États-Unis mais est-ce qu'on
vous on voit ou du moins au sud m
prenons l'exemple encore du Québec
évidemment parce qu'on est là mais on
voit qu'est-ce qui s'en vient en terme
d'effet est-ce qu'on peut aussi prévoir
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire en terme
d'adaptation en voyant qu'est-ce qui se
fait mettons je donner ex exemple
absolument débile parce que c'est c'est
sûr ça sera pas ça qui va se passer
j'imagine corrigez-moi si je me trompe
on voit qu'en 2005 va faire un climat
ici comme il fait actuellement en
Floride fait qu'on commence à planter
des orangiers main pour faire pour pour
avoir des oranges est-ce que c'est le
genre d'affaire qui qu'on pense quand
qu'on pense à l'adaptation en se disant
ok il va falloir qu'on aille qu'on
cultive des choses va falloir cultiver
comme il va
faire transformation profonde ou ouis
absolument en agriculture c'est c'est le
bon jus d'orange du Québec des oranges
mais les viings c'est un bon exemple on
a des viingrons oui c'est ça mais c'est
un bon exemple les les les vigrons au
Québec font du vin font du vin depuis
longtemps au Québec mais là les les
sépages qui sont qui sont en train
d'essayer de cultiver c'est en fonction
des changements climatiques ils sont
capables de cultiver des choses qui
étaient pas capables de cultiver les
agriculteurs de manière générale
regardent beaucoup ce qu'il y a dans le
sud
pour tester des choses euh sur leur TER
territoire en forêt c'est la même chose
on parle de migration assité là on
commence à faire des tests de si on
plantait ça déjà plus au nord on va
planter des essences qui vont être
adapté déjà au climat de demain
aujourd'hui ils vont aller un peu mal
parce que c'est pas c'est pas prêt tout
suite mais donc c'est c'est le genre de
de test qui font puis ça ça vient de de
de regarder ce qu'on appelle un analogue
là qu'est-ce qui se passe ailleurs ce
qui s'en vient de de de voir ce qui s'en
vient ici qui est déjà ailleurs on se
compare puis on essaie des choses donc
ou ça ça ça se fait c'est fou ça wouh B
j'avais jamais même j'avais jamais même
pensé à ça avant notre conversation j'ai
jamais même pensé à quand évidemment que
le climat va ressembl à un climat qui
existe ailleur dans le monde va falloir
changer ça ouais mais ressembler mais tu
sais avec quand même des différences
aussi tu sais le point de vue
géomorphologique c'est pas la même chose
tu sais il y a la faonde la flur on voit
des des des espèces qui arrivent du Sud
qui sont présentes maintenant mant il y
a des choses c'est très agréable mais il
y a des problèmes aussi puis des fois
c'est des des espèces qui ont pas
néèement de prédateur puis là ça amène
tout un bouleversement des écosystème
donc c'est des questions hyper complexes
là puis au niveau de l'adaptation au
niveau planétaire mettons est-ce que
est-ce qu'on est capable déjà savoir il
A- des zones déjà qu'on sait qui seront
plus habitables il a-t- des grands
bouleversements des grandes migrations
qu'on qu'on attend ou on le sait pas ou
mais comme on le disait tantôt je pense
les grandes sécheresses en terme de de
de de sécurité alimentaire les les les
endroits dans le monde où c'est déjà
difficile en terme d'agriculture puis en
terme de de ressources ça va être de
plus en plus difficile donc on s'attend
à ce que ces régionsl subissent des des
des épisodes de migration même à faire
avec l'élévation de de la mer c'est les
côtes c'est les petites les petites îles
insulaires qui sont déjà au R à r la mer
donc ça c'est c'est probablement des
enjeux les plus importants que je peux
auquels je peux penser là de de manière
planétaire puis ça c'est ce que ça a
déjà commencé aujourd'hui oui oui oui
oui c'est ça ah ou il y a déjà des
réfugiés climatiques là c'est quoi tu
valu ça se peut je me mélange peut-être
au quiir bâti c'est des îles Pacifique
puis je ils ont dû quitter oui ils sont
des réfugiés climatiques je sais plus si
c'est en Australie ou en
Nouvelle-Zélande en tout cas mais un des
deux il me semble qu'il les a accueill
en tant que tel là parce que je veux
dire le niveau de la mer fait en sorte
que quand il y a un événement plus
intense
ben juste le fait que ce soit plus dans
le sens que tu un ouragan qui frappe il
y a l'ouragan pas besoin d'être plus
fort ou plus intense mais juste si ton
niveau de la mè est plus élevé ben il va
faire plus de de de dommage et c'est ce
qui déjà ce qui se
produit faut se préparer à ça aussi en
tant que société plus nordique et
privilégié de d'accueillir ces
changements là puis ces gensl qui vont
subir le le le plus gros plus de d'effet
que nous plus directement ouais tout à
fait et
un autre un autre on parle d'adaptation
d'un point de vue planification puis
structurelle depuis tout à l'heure
est-ce que l'être humain peut s'adapter
aussi p ou on a'ura pas assez de temps
pour modifier notre je pense que l'être
humain comme tel habite déjà dans de
multiples zones sur la terre là mais
mettons moi j'ai moi j'ai moins de fun
quand je vois mettons euh quand je vois
au Mexique qu' qu'un quelqu'un qui est
né là qui
qui est habitué là tu sais ok dans ce
sens là
acclimater ouais acclimater peut-être là
ouais ouais je sais pas c'est une bonne
question on me l'a jamais posé
c très bonne question on atu le temps ça
je j'imagine que oui honnêtement là je
pense que tu sa tu sais si tu arrives
dans un je tu passes 6 mois dans un pays
chaud et les premiers temps tu souffres
beaucoup puis après quelques semaines
quelques mois tu tu habitues
tranquillement je suppose que c'est la
même chose des gens qui ont émigré ici
les premiers hivers ils sont r dans
tabarouette oua c'est ça mais après
quelquesuns tu sais en général il y en a
même qui prennent plaisir ouais ouais
mais bon c'est les plus fous de la
gangne
ah puis est-ce qu'on sait au niveau de
la biodiversité tu sais euh h mais 3
degrés de réchauffement c'est quoi parce
que c'est sûr que il y a des effets
dominaux làdedans dans le sens que
exemple si le plancton peut plus
survivre c'est toute la chaîne
alimentaire qui qui en découle la pêche
et Cera puis euh est-ce que est-ce que
nos données sont précises là-dessus non
non puis le problème c'est que les
changements climatique ça s'ajoute à
plein d'autres choses c'est ça s'ajoute
à la pollution ça s'ajoute à la
surexploitation des ressources c'est ça
on pas parler de pollution
de toutes d'autres affaires encore pour
un autre podcast oui c'est ça avec d'aut
mond
ou que je pense tu sais le le la
biodiversité pour moi c'est majeur ouais
parce que ça plus que les changements
climatiques pris de ma façon isolée je
dirais parce que justement c'est ça comp
ouais c'est tellement complexe c'est
tellement fondamental ouais on sait pas
comme on disait là il y a des il y a des
choses qui nous arrivent du Sud comment
ça va réagir avec les essences les
espèces qu'on a ici on a aucune espèce
d'idée il y a pas de test là on peut pas
mettre ça en laboratoire dans un on sait
pas là il y a plein de de facteurs
inconnus qu'on vit puis qu'on étudie
live pendant que ça se produit
parce que tu sais nous justement tu sais
peut-être que part notre intelligence on
peut trouver des Maur de s'adapter mais
si la nature s'adapte pas on est on est
on a encore besoin de la nature là je
pense pas que l'humain est autosuffisant
non en même temps comme on disa il y a
de la nature quand même dans le sud
c'est la nature ici elle va être
différente parce que ça va juste devenir
autre chose ça va ça va devenir autre
chose puis on il y a des espèces
envaillissantes déjà qu'on voit qui ont
pris le contrôle de nos écosystèmes lesx
les Cox alzatique la coccinell ça il y a
plein de cxinell céé les cxinelles ou
c'est pas les
cinell sont ici les cxinelles
ou sont vraiment pénibl exc
iérience personnelle
avec vont rentrer bientôt dans les
maisons il va commencer à faire fr avoir
encore plus mais c'est ça la fragm sur
le B des routes on on a il y a déjà
plusieurs exemples la maladie de li
qu'on avait pas avant avec la souris de
la sour pte blanche qui est l'autre qui
qui fait en sorte que ça descend
tranquillement ça
monte vers n ça monte de plus en plus
vers le N donc déjà des choses on voit
déjà en esprit enoupou il comm avoir
ailleurs ça apparaît tranquillement ou
ououis donc mais ça on fait pas
nécessairement prédire puis on sait pas
jusqu' où ça va aller puis on sait pas
les interactions justement cette fameuse
souris à pâte blanche avec les autres
souris dans l'écosystème
ou c'est une infinité de variables c'est
une infinité de combinaisons possible
qu'on peut pas prévoir en plus plus mais
quand même c'est c'est un équilibre en
fait que que sa qui s'est bâti sur des
millions d'années puis que tout d'un
coup
ouaiséquilibré en quelques en 200 ans
c'est pas ma à faire comme on disait
surtout que c'est pas juste les
changements climatique c'est
l'ensembleble de l'empreunte de l'humain
exactement très intéressant où est-ce
que où est-ce que les gens peuvent en
apprendre plus peuvent suivre ce que
vous faites peuvent s'il y a des des des
gens qui n écoute qui veulent organiser
une conférence je sais pas c'est
qu'est-ce que vous offrez c'est quoi
c'est le moment de ploguer les le plug
du podcast le blog du podcast le ben on
a déjà on a un site web où il y a quand
même pas mal d'information il y a une
section comprendre les changements
climatiques avec des des thématiques
vulgarisé là on essaie justement
d'expliquer qu'est-ce qui s'en vient en
terme d'impact sur différents secteurs
on a des des portails un portail qui
s'appelle portrait climatique qui
détaille vous pouvez aller chercher
cliquer votre municipalité puis aller
voir qu'est-ce qui s vient en terme de
de changement climatique on est vas-y
oua mais c'est ça je faut pas oublier
aussi an c'est un consortium parce que
souvent quand on parle on va dire on
nous mais il faut pas oublier que c'est
pas juste les employés d'Ouranos c'est
tout le consortium donc par juste un
exemple en tête l'INSPQ l'Institut
national de la santé publique du Québec
a fait beaucoup de choses par rapport au
changement climatique et à la santé donc
les gens qui s'intéressent à des
thématique particulièr peuvent aller
mais notamment la santé par exemple
peuvent avoir uneination sur le site de
l'INSP
mais déjà si vous contactez l'adresse
info à touranos on vous redirige là vers
les chercheurs comme Dominique le dit
c'est pas nous on tout le temps on va
vous vous rediriger vers les bonnes
personnes vers les Bones organisations
qui vont avoir les réponses à vous
donner sur des thématiques spécifiques
au besoins c'est ça sinon en fait une PR
on fait pas Rana c'est pas de mandat
publicque en tant que tel donc on fait
pas de conférence c'est ça comme ça euh
bon comment je pourrais dire ça ça
arrive qu'on en fait ok mais c'est plus
des décisions personnelles ou quoi que
ce soit ou tout ça ou il y a des fois il
y a des mandats spécifiques qui vont
nous être donnés mais a priori urana
c'est vraiment là pour servir ben ses
membres mais c'estes membres comme je
dis c'est le gouvernement du Québec
c'est c'est en fait c'est toute la
société québécoise et même plus que ça
dans son ensemble mais a priori c'est ça
on n pas de mandat public donc c'est ça
je comprends la précision oui on va
mettre le lien vers anos dans la
description du balado puis merci
beaucoup pour cette conversation là
c'était super intéressant merci à vous
merci